[Music]
thank you
come on I've been happening okay
okay
[Music]
you can even take overnight sometimes a
day can pass or two okay
foreign
[Music]
Grace so I went home to catch up some
rest
around 23 hours I had a Nook at my door
two women were knocking they said they
brought a woman in labor
so I thought maybe it was guess not
until they explained no it's just
another
a woman who's come for labor
yeah
[Music]
after examining that's when I saw that
this is a serious kiss the Fatal art was
less than 100 the baby was in distress
so I had to cut the ambulance though due
to network failure
the lines wouldn't go through
the head was delivered and they showed
us couldn't rotate when the baby came
out it wouldn't cry
when the baby aspirated in Korean there
was no suction machine there was only a
penguin soccer which wouldn't go deep
and remove those secretions I had to
unbu back the baby but without good
effect the baby died
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
1984.
[Music]
foreign
I'm 55 years old now
I'm a farmer I normally grow Maize
groundnuts green beans and some tomato
now married to Grace chibilica and I've
stayed with my wife for now 16 years and
I have four children with her the fifth
is not yet
born
yes
Papa
foreign
[Music]
oh my God
to my first wife I've got five children
they were supposed to be eight but the
three died dirty and eight age over
their ages
[Music]
the first born daughter was memory she
had malaria she died at the age of four
years
when I lost my second bone I almost lost
my life because it trained me a lot
friends came to advise me to those other
friends that also lost their their
children why should you lose your life
just because of this what has happened
to you then the third one immediately
was delivered she only stayed maybe one
hour 30 minutes
then the infant died
to experience death at that age you see
your friend playing with his baby I only
thought why Always On Me well my friends
are keeping their children but I never
took up my life
I don't Lose My Faith cause I know
that death is there
what I only did was to get more advices
how to keep myself my children
and that's what I'm still doing now
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
ambulance
so please I beg he wants every TV series
foreign
[Music]
attended
examine
yeah foreign
[Music]
baby we need a suction machine we need
catheters to empty the woman's bladder
when they are in labor we need
sterilization machine but for here
katoba we do not have those instruments
this building it has solar lighting so
in the rain Seasons we have to use our
phones for lighting we learn to
improvise because when there are no
things at least you you try to think
instead of letting a woman to suffer
this Clinic is just for normal
deliveries and a complicated delivery
which has just to be repaired
if the nurse notices that something has
gone wrong then the nurse will call the
hospital for an ambulance to go and pick
the patient
okay let me just call the ambulance then
where can we go
[Music]
right now we're responding to a call
she's about 10 kilometers away from the
main hospital
they are calling us
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and they have to come to a hospital
where there's facilities for theater and
so we then intervene by doing a cesarean
section
[Music]
so we we have a big challenge because
you know we have 39 facilities being
serviced by one ambulance a population
of close to 200 000 people and these
facilities are not like concentrated in
one place to go into katova which is one
of our furthest facilities it takes
about 1 hour 30 minutes
we have this huge challenge the nurse
calls for an ambulance in facility X
which is 50 kilometers away says this
woman is bleeding and then we have
another nurse calling from another
facility says I have another one who has
failed to deliver so now we are left
with a dilemma because you have to
decide where do you go to pick the
patient
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the Blues
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
uncle
[Music]
foreign
3.5 kg
um
I think if he
I have a daughter who
who has completed school maybe she goes
up to college she might become a
president she might become a minister
she might become a doctor
[Music]
teacher Mysteries
do you plan to have more kids after this
one no I'm not planning I think this
will be the last key
why do you think this is the last one
are they enough that I have us at now
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
please
foreign
[Music]
months
she is at the nursery school
is
[Music]
foreign